Most onscreen versions of Superman and Batman
have looked a lot like they do in the original
DC Comics, but not all superheroes are created
equal.
Some of the most iconic superheroes have received
major makeovers when they jumped off the printed
page.
Here’s how DC superheroes should really
look.
Superman
There is no shortage of angry fans' gripes
about the DC Extended Universe version of
Superman...but his appearance probably isn't
one of them.
Though it's not an exact replica of the comics
character's usual threads, Henry Cavill's
physical appearance for the role isn't one
of the DC Extended Universe's problems.
Unless, that is, you really like red underpants.
One of the most prominent distinctions of
the new Kal-El costume is the fact that, like
everything else about the modern take, it's
much darker.
Whereas the Superman of old donned bright
blue tights with bright red accents and a
cape, the new suit is somewhere in the deep
denim family.
With a scaly texture woven throughout, Superman's
super-suit appears much rougher than the leotards
of Krypton's past.
And, of course, it's not hard to miss the
fact that Cavill's costume also ditches the
thick belt and outer britches featured in
the drawings.
It makes sense, too...Superman's original
outer-underpants design was based on that
of circus strongmen of the late 19th and early
20th centuries.
That's not really a thing anymore, so it’s
probably okay to drop the underoos...they
finally have in the comics, too.
Batman
In 2016's super-punch-fest, Dawn of Justice,
Ben Affleck's Batman was most obviously inspired
by the Caped Crusader's journey in the 1986
comic miniseries The Dark Knight Returns.
In the four-part Frank Miller epic, an older
Bruce returns from retirement to combat rampant
violence that has taken over Gotham City and
dukes it out with Superman along the way.
His costume, too, is clearly inspired by the
series.
The slate gray color, shorter "ears" on the
cowl, and the size and shape of the bat-emblem,
is pretty much a direct mirror of Miller's
vision, and the surest giveaway for the Batfleck's
true inspiration.
Well, that, and the fact that he basically
said it in an interview.
"Zack was heavily influenced by that, I think
everyone's heavily influenced by that, that's
the seminal work.
So, I don't think there's any of these that
have been made that haven't drawn from that
book, because it's so good."
Wonder Woman
Lynda Carter's version of Wonder Woman from
the '70s TV show established a very literal
rendition of the iconic DC character.
But when Gal Gadot re-introduced Wonder Woman
in Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice, she
did it in an updated outfit.
Instead of the red, yellow, and blue primary
color scheme she typically wears in the comics,
she dons metallic body armor that fits in
nicely beside the new, grittier versions of
Batman and Superman.
Based on that and what she's worn in footage
from 2017's Wonder Woman feature, it seems
that the amazing Amazon's classic outfit has
been translated nearly perfectly to the big
screen.
Aquaman
While other superheroes have a long history
of on-screen adaptations, Aquaman has only
appeared on television a handful of times...and
all of them favored his usual orange and green
style.
Instead, actor Jason Momoa seems to borrow
more from Aquaman’s later, more grizzled
look, wearing a costume that highlights his
incredible brawn.
It's basically Poseidon meets Khal Drogo.
And that's awesome.
Still, this version of Aquaman will always
be closest to our hearts.
(weird Aquaman sounds)
"Oh, hello old chum."
Green Arrow
Green Arrow's costume on television has gone
through some tweaks, but none have quite lined
up with the Emerald Archer's longtime look
from the comics.
While the original is a not-so-subtle tribute
to Robin Hood, Stephen Amell looks far darker
and more leathery in the new suit.
Additionally, for Arrow's first season, Ollie
didn't even bother wearing anything to cover
his face, opting instead for black greasepaint.
Eventually he wised up and went with a mask,
while keeping the practical and modernized
hood to go with the show's urban setting.
The Flash
What happens when you have a TV show about
a superhero, but you want to include the same
character in your movies without impacting
either one?
You end up with Grant Gustin and Ezra Miller
both playing a dude named Barry Allen, the
Flash, the fastest man alive.
Well, the fastest fictional man alive, at
least.
The costume from the CW's TV series is mostly
faithful to the comic book original, but it's
a deeper shade of red and has some unique
style choices: there's the lightning bolt
seams in the headpiece that reflects his New
52 comic counterpart, the fact that his boots
are red instead of the signature yellow, and
the the lightning trimmings from his waist
and forearms have been reduced and removed,
respectively.
"I'm the Flash"
"The who now?"
Ezra Miller's movie Flash is even more distinct,
looking almost like he’s wearing armor.
The inspiration for Miller's movie Flash,
it seems, is the character's look in the Injustice
video game series.
In fact, Gustin has declared himself a fan
of the new Flash aesthetic, calling it "sick"
and adding that he's "glad it's really different"
and takes a different approach than the TV
show's "street, vintage feel."
Hopefully one day they'll actually meet, and
we'll get a true "Flash of Two Worlds" style
crossover.
Nerds can dream, can't they?
Kid Flash
Kid Flash's costume got a few alterations
in The Flash TV series, too.
The costume worn by TV's Wally West has a
mustardy hue rather than a primary yellow,
and sewn-in gloves, as opposed to the separate
pieces in the comics.
Meanwhile, his belt is thicker and distinct,
with a deeper shade of red.
Of course, one of the most significant and
interesting changes is that this version of
Kid Flash is African-American, a new spin
on a character who for years in the comics
was white.
Because comics are endlessly confusing, there
is a comic book version of Kid Flash who reflects
this new interpretation...but no matter who
you think of as Wally West, that's still a
pretty darn accurate costume.
The Atom
While there are some nods to the old comics
rendition of the Atom, the character's on-screen
adaptation seems to have included a full-on
molecular transformation from his original
appearance.
Brandon Routh's outfit incorporates pieces
of Atom's upgrade from DC Comics' New 52 reboot,
like his exosuit and armored helmet in place
of his mask.
Andy Poon, the concept artist who created
the new costume, wrote that the decision to
replace the character's signature spandex
suit was for practical reasons, but he still
"tried to emulate the feel of the traditional
blue and red pattern as much as possible while
keeping it more on the grounded sci-fi armor."
Martian Manhunter
The Manhunter from Mars, alternately known
as J'onn J'onzz, has been through a lot of
changes over his many eras of fictional existence,
and his live-action adaptation in TV's Supergirl
adds to the character's evolutionary history.
On the show, David Harewood's makeup-enhanced
look for Martian Manhunter draws from bits
and pieces of his comic past—the shape of
his head mirrors the New 52 style, while his
cross-shaped red chest design seems like more
of a nod to the style he's rocked for years.
Meanwhile, the shape of his eyes and the spherical
orbs on his costume are callbacks to the Martian's
2006 standalone miniseries, while the costume
itself seems like a militarized version of
what the character was drawn with in the cartoon
Justice League: Doom.
Even so, the Martian's TV version stands on
its own.
Supergirl
If you're a superhero, chances are good you've
gone through a few significant costume changes
here and there.
And that's more true for Supergirl than most.
So when Warner Brothers decided to bring the
Girl of Steel to the small screen, they had
plenty of outfits to choose from—which showrunners
poked fun at during the show's pilot episode:
"I'm not flying around saving people in this
thing.
I wouldn't wear this to the beach.
Where's my cape?"
"Cape's are lame!"
Fortunately, good sense prevailed and Melissa
Benoist's Supergirl wears what's probably
the character's best version of the outfit.
Even with the textured fabric that's become
a staple of live-action superheroics, the
Supergirl costume has all the most important
elements, from the bold blue top to the bright
red boots, skirt, and cape.
It's indisputable: Supergirl's definitely
the best-dressed hero on television.
"Nice to meet you by the way."
"Nice to meet you too!"
"I really like your outfit."
"I like your glasses."
"Thanks!"
Wish we could say the same thing for the Red
Tornado.
Yikes.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
live-action DC heroes you think look the best.